Je vais là mon mon petit h de début. Tu
es pas pessimiste, la s tu as été
entraîné à l' je sais pas encore par
qui. C'est probablement les personnes
les plus proches de toi. Donc ça ça va
être qu'est-ce qui va starter la vidéo ?
C'est le pessimiste
à qui qu'on te transmis.
surtout au Québec même, j'imagine qu'
partout dans le monde mais là je peux je
parle du Québec parce que c'est ça que
j'ai et que je vis en ce moment mais
on est rapidement négatif au Québec, on
l' très très rapidement puis même on met
même pas ça sur le mot de négatif, on
met ça sur le mot de réaliste. C'est ça
qui est encore plus
impactant parce que c'est
le fait de voir les choses réalistes.
C'est comme si tu es tu es réaliste, tu
es
tu es tu sais c'est logique de penser
comme ça. Mais s on va voir dans cette
vidéo là que c'est pas du tout réaliste
de penser. pas du tout.
Peut-être que c'est réaliste
au niveau des probabilités peut-être,
mais est-ce que c'est la bonne manière
de penser ? Certainement pas.
sincèrement
penser ta vie. Tu sais, j'ai j'avais un
script là, mais je pas tout parti passer
là-dedans. Mais je travaille dans une
école en ce moment comme backup puis
je côtois régulièrement des
des concierges des concierges que je
parle c'est de d'alimenter la discussion
puis de prendre des nouvelles de eux
parce que je sais que il y a pas un
grand monde qui s'arrête pour parler de
eux comment qu'ils vont puis tout.
Puis c'est en parlant avec ces gens-là
que je me rends compte que
le fait d'être négatif, ça détruit toute
ta vie, toutes tes décisions.
Ça détruit tout ton potentiel, ça le
détruit parce que tu vas avoir une idée
peut-être d'aller voyager à l'autre bout
du monde, mais étant donné que tu es
négatif mais que tu te qualifies comme
réaliste, tu vas pas y aller dans le
voyage parce que tu vas te dire "Hey euh
telle personne est allée puis elle a est
tombé de son scooter puis elle s'est
cassé le bras puis elle était tout seul
puis e je vais pas aller là-bas là c'est
pas réaliste de de d'y aller là les
chances que ça se passe pas bien mais
sont pas mal plus forte que si je
ressuscite. Oui, effectivement les
chances que ça que je veux dire, tu
sais, c'est sûr que en restant chez
vous, ben c'est sûr que il se passe pas
grand-chose de négatif, mais il se passe
pas grandchose de positif, hein. Fait
que c'est sûr, mais passer ta vie dans
ce mindset là, tu fais rien de ta vie.
Tu fais rien de ta vie. Tu fais rien de
risqué dans ta vie. Puis ça, je trouve
que c'est tellement triste du monde qui
prennent pas de risque dans leur vie. Je
dis juste qu'ils vont même pas essayer,
qu'ils vont même pas
avoir une lueur d'espoir de
je le fais euh je sais que c'est risqué,
je sais qu'il y a des chances que ça
marche pas, il y a des chances sont
quand même assez grandes, ça marche pas
mais euh j'ai voulu essayer pareil parce
que j'ai une vie à vivre puis oui, tu en
as une vie à vivre. Donc là genre
prends-en des risques, prends-en des
risques. On s'en fout de qu'est-ce que
le monde pense. Puis ça le au final
c'est un réflexe qui est mental. C'est
un réflexe mental qu'on a que qu'on que
tu as développé avec les années.
Donc ça vient à une une expérience euh
scientifique, je sais pas c'est quoi le
nom exact de cette expérience là, mais
c'était le le pessimiste
appris.
ou le pessimiste
en tout cas le pessimiste a pris je
pense
il mettait des rats dans euh
dans deux bocales avec de l'eau. Puis
il mettait le le rat dans le dans le
bocal puis devait se tu sais lui il
patogeait pour survivre
puis il laissait jusqu'àattant que le
le le R va arrêter de nanger parce qu'il
va il va réaliser que il y a pas de
source de sortie, il peut pas survivre
donc il va arrêter de nager puis il va
mourir. Il va il va se noyer.
Deuxè deuxè test, ils font la même chose
avec un autre R dans un bocal avec de
l'eau. Le R patose patoge patose. Puis
quand il est rendu au stade où c'est que
ils savent qu'il va mourir, ben qu'il va
arrêter, il va se laisser mourir dans
les prochaines euh
minutes, secondes, peu importe, il sort
de l'eau.
C'est là que ça commence à être
intéressant parce que là après ça si par
exemple là je connais pas les les les
temps et cetera là mais si par exemple
le premier r
il a arrêté de nager après 10 minutes
puis il est mort après parce qu'il plus
d'espoir l'autre qui était sorti de
l'eau à dernière seconde lui tu l' dans
un bocal
je pense qu'
st
même
Bon ben ça c'est un autre apprentissage
à mes vidéos avoir les bonnes stats.
Mais après ça le euh le rat il restait
genre trois quatre fois plus longtemps
dans l'eau sans arrêter de nanger parce
qu'il avait l'espoir parce qu'il savait
que il allait peut-être se faire sauver
puis avait un potentiel de de survivre
de de de
sortir de l'eau.
C'est l'optimisme appris. Donc apprendre
à être optimiste, à être positif, à voir
le positif, à toujours voir la lueur
d'espoir.
Puis ça, oui, ça se fait avec tes
expériences vécues, mais ça se fait
encore plus avec tes relations autour de
toi. Donc, on dit souvent, tu es la
somme des cinq personnes que tu côtois
le plus.
Ben ça si tu es cinq personnes que tu
côes le plus là eux autres là si ils
vivent une mauvaise journée ben c'est la
faute d' c'est la faute de si c'est la
faute de ça c'est jamais leur faute sont
tout en mode négatif négatif tu le tu
leur parles d'un projet de business tu
leur parles un projet de peu importe tu
parles à telle personne peu importe puis
ils vont toujours être dans le négatif
de he me semble c'est risqué là tu
l'affaire ou ça c'est je sais pas moi
c'est cette personne tu pas la côtoyer
parce que à elle se lance en affaire
puis c'est risqué ses affaires puis là
ça se peut qu'elle te demande l'argent
tout le temps être axé dans la partie
qui est négative toujours sa défensive
puis ça ben tu t'imprègnes de ces
personnesl puis tu deviens comme eux
d'où l'importance de te entourer de gens
qui sont positifs que même si toi tu es
peut-être tuas peut-être un réflexe que
tu développé avec les années d'être
négatif
Ben va rencontrer des gens qui sont
positifs de nature de nature qui ont
développé ça parce que ça se développe
ça. C'est un skill que tu développes
dans ta tête, c'est un réflexe mental
que tu développes d'être positif, de
voir les choses de manière positive. Pu
ça ça change tout dans ta vie. Ça change
tout. C'est hyper simple. C'est hyper
simple, mais c'est un réflexe qu'on a
mental qui est euh très
que les risques
puis les euh
le danger de ça, ça paraît pas, on
dirait dans les ça paraît pas sur le
cour terme, mais c'est sur le long
terme. Le long terme, ça fait des
ravages. Tu es tu as pas du tout le même
potentiel. tu as pas du tout la même vie
vécue
en développant ce mindset là de
d'être réaliste slash négatif puis
d'être positif.
Peut-être que je mélange les idées là,
mais je le vois justement on revient à
l'idée à l'exemple des des concierges
que j'utilisais puis il me disait toutes
les choses qui me disent les discussions
c'est sur le négatif sur des choses qui
ne les contrôlent pas mais qui ne le
contrôle pas qui qui subit tout le temps
des choses qui subissent tout le temps.
Ils ne contrôlent pas. C'est tout le
temps le gouvernement, leur employeur,
leur curs ça, leur femmes, l'argent, le
gouvernement, tu sais, tout le temps,
ils subissent, il subissent, c'est tof
la vie puis tout puis tout est négatif.
Il y a rien de positif. C'est tout le
temps ça. Je tout le temps sa défensive,
tout le temps en mode défensif, tout le
temps. Il me disait ça, il me disait e
Mathias,
méfie-toi de tout. Il dit, méfie-toi de
ton nombre. méfie-toi de ton nombre.
Tu sais, c'est des choses que
si tu passenses ta vie à te méfier de
tout,
tu vas pas jamais t'associer avec des
gens pour des projets entrepreneuriux.
Tu vas jamais te montrer
dans des vidéos, dans du contenu parce
qu'ils ont peur d'être jugés. tu vas
jamais prendre des risques, tu vas
jamais voyager, tu vas jamais euh
investir, tu vas jamais sais avoir des
employés, ça prend ça prend une
confiance, ça prend soit positif,
tu sais avoir des sais ça va tout le
temps, il va avoir des parties qui sont
risquées mais si tu vois juste la partie
négative des risques, tu vas te limiter
à un monde fabuleux
qui est la vie au final. La vie c'est
ça, c'est prendre des risques, c'est
d'essayer des choses dans ta vie. Donc
euh
c'est ça. Si c'est conditionné à la
base, tu peux le reconditionner
en t'entourant de gens qui sont plus
positifs
puis en te focalisant sur ton esprit,
sur ton réflexe mental. Donc deux choses
à faire après cette vidéo là.
Un, regarde les cinq personnes avec qui
que tu tu ces le plus.
demande-toi honnêtement là, je lis mon
mes notes, mais après avoir parlé avec
cette personnelà, est-ce que tu te sens
plus capable ou moins capable
de peu importe de tes projets, de tes de
ton ambition ? C'est pas là pour fuir,
c'est pour être conscient de leur
influence sur ton conditionnement. Donc
demande-toi, est-ce que après avoir
parlé à cette personneelà, est-ce que je
me sens plus capable de réaliser mes
rêves, d'aller dans mes ambitions ou je
me sens moins capable ? parce qu'il m'a
plus parlé de choses négatives, m'a plus
parlé des risques, il m'a plus parlé de
faudrait que tu penses à telle telle
telle affaire parce que tel telle
affaire pourrait faire perdre l'argent
du temps de c'est du risque.
Donc ça premier point deuxème point
la prochaine fois qu'il y a quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas pour toi
comme tu t'attendais,
force-toi à trouver une explication
temporaire et précise. Donc te dire ça
l' pas marché à cause de c
je ne suis je suis pas fait pour ça
juste une se phrase c'est début c'est
pas marché ouais
aussi
deè point c'est quand tuas un jugement
critique sur quelque chose qui est
arrivé qui était négatif jugement
négatif que tu réalises
pos question.
Telle chose n'est pas arrivé comme je le
pensais parce que
peut-être j'ai je n'ai pas fait ça, je
n'ai pas été assez discipliné, je n'ai
pas été assez ça. Donc là, tu vas
tourner le la chose négative en
apprentissage.
Après ça là,
tout ce qui se passe qui est pas comme
tu le voulais se transforme en
j'apprends de ça. Je deviens meilleur
dans ce que je fais dans ma vie puis
j'évolue. Donc tu transformes le négatif
en positif. Puis de toujours avoir ce
réflexe mental de
tourner le négatif en positif. Puis
comme ça, tu vas réaliser, le monde va
s'ouvrir à toi. J'en suis convaincu.